يشترط في شرعيه الزواج المندائي ان يحضر
مراسيم الزواج رجل دين بمرتبه كنزفره ورجل
دين بمرتبه ترميذه
ولعل هم مراسيم الزواج البندئي هو التعميد
في الماء الجاري حيث يعتقد المندليون انه
يبعث الطهاره والنقاء في النفس
الولاده الاولى من رحم الام الولاده
الثانيه الزواج والولاده الثالثه والوفاه
الوفاه والولاده من عالم مادي الى عالم
روحاني الخروج من هذا العالم الماليه
بشرور والماليه بالقتل والمليء بالنفاق
الى عالم زكي الى عالم نور الى عالم لا
رائحه كريهه فيها
ف الزواج عندما ياتي العروسين نعمدهم في
الماء الجاري اين صبغهم
ولكي يتخلصوا ويكونوا طاهرين نقيين لايذاء
القسم والبدء حياه جديده زوجيه جديده
جديده
بعد ان يلبسوا هذه الملابس القطنيه
البيضاء
ويتعمد ونقول للعريس
هذا قسم
بالحي العظيم ان تحافظ على قرينتك تعزها
وتكرمها لا تاكل ولا تشرب بدونها كن عصاها
التي تتوكل عليها ايام المحل ابتعد عن
الخمره والسرقه والكذب لانها تدمر حياتك
الزوجيه هذا ما امرني به ربي وانا امرك ان
تلتزم به وكذلك للعروسه نقول لها هذا قسم
ان تحافظ على زوجك بالسراء في صحته ومرضه
في حضوره في غيبته في ماله وعرضه
ونتمنى لهم حياه زوجيه بعد اجراء البراسيم
الدينيه الخاصه لهم
لم يشفع تاريخ الطائفه المندائيه الذي
يعود الى الاف السنين لاعطائها اهميه اكثر
وتمثيلا سياسيا اوسع لقد اصبحت طائفه
المندائيه مهدده بالزوال خاصه ان اغلب
ابناءها يهاجرون بحثا عن الامن والقوت في
ظل غياب برامج حكوميه للاهتمام بحقوق
الاقليات الدينيه والعرقيه على حساب
محافظات سياسيه قد تاتي على ما بقي من
فسيفساء دينيه وعرقيه طالما ميزته المجتمع
العراقي